so long as we leave love
unexamined so long as we don't look
candidly at the failures and dangers of
love as we experience it that's why I
say that
we're summoned
to love the unlovable in ourselves which
includes our own failures in love
[Music]
we think that love is essentially a
matter of strong individual attachment
and that very easily turns into
something which is a source of strong
affirmation for myself
and goes alongside strong aversion for
the other
and in both of the spiritual Traditions
that I
I value well I value Lots but
particularly I think my own Christian
tradition but what I've also learned
from Buddhism there's a sort of
skepticism here about living your life
on this pendulum between strong
attachment and strong aversion
and there's something else I think going
on that we have to live our way into
which is called love
mostly because it's not destructive it's
not
um cannibalizing of the other and I
found a useful text for that when
recently on an airplane I was watching
Rita goig's film ladybird which some of
you I think will have seen and the
elderly nun at one point in that film
points out to
um young ladybird Christine that the way
she writes about Sacramento this term
which she says she hates
suggests that she loves it because she's
paying attention she's paying intense
attention to the particularity of it
and says well maybe that's you know
that's love
now to take another French writer
milacan's remarks are very pertinent but
going back a bit further Simon Vey one
of the great mid-century French
philosophers speaks very eloquently in
terms of how attention is what we
constantly have to learn because
attention is what takes us away from the
focus on the strength of our feeling and
into the sheer
density the sheerness of the other
it's self-forgetful
not self-obliterating
but if I'm utterly preoccupied with
attending
and that's what happens when a musician
performs it what happens happens in
personal love it what happened what
happened
what happens in a number of other
contexts
my ego and its agenda is for that moment
parked
I'm taken up with something that's not
simply confined by my wants my intensity
of my feelings
and the result is ideally we we grow
together
myself and the the object of of the
attention
so I think that's that's where I'd want
to start in talking about a love that
isn't just
about intense subjectivity which isn't
just about
oceans of
positive feeling washing around
and which certainly is very skeptical
about all those I say very aware of all
those risks
which Renata has just spoken of in terms
of
making the other perform my script in
one way or another foreign
so the conceptual points I want to raise
about romantic love can be nicely
illustrated by one of the speeches in
Plato's Dialogue on Eros the Symposium
now Eros of course is erotic love but
the speech of Aristophanes the comic
poet uh describes something very very
close to our late 18th early 19th
century conception of romantic love
so he he gives us a fable in which
originally there were proto-humans who
were entirely spherical with their two
faces on one head two sets of arms two
sets of legs two sets of genitalia and
they sort of bounded around the earth
like acrobats and uh brought they didn't
have sex as we know it they kind of uh
conceived upon the ground like crickets
but they got too big for their many
boots and they threatened the gods and
Zeus and the other gods wanted to cut
them down to size but didn't want to
annihilate them completely because they
liked all the Libations and the
sacrifices and the general worship
so they cut them in half physically cut
them in half
and then you get this notion that each
person is going I say person inverted
comments because as we'll see it's not
clear they are people is going around
the world literally searching for their
other half and aristophony says we don't
care whether this other half is good or
bad beautiful or ugly it is the fact
that they are ours they are part of us
and because originally there had been
three uh Sexes male female and
hermaphrodite and the circular beings
that accounts for heterosexuality and
male and female homosexuality
nah this raises some really interesting
philosophical questions
one uh when if if it happens that one of
these halves meets another half they
yearn to be reunited they actually want
the blacksmith God advised us to reunite
them into one body with his blacksmith's
tools
and this race is a really problematic
ethical issue and also metaphysical one
the ethical issue is that yes the story
captures the fact that we see the other
as unique there is only one other half
for us and irreplaceable uh a particular
unique uh Irreplaceable but do we see
them as an individual in their own right
or simply as are missing half the
missing bit of us which we want to
reabsorb into us just as of course the
other person wants to reabsorb us into
them and that raises both troubling
ethical issues and of course also
metaphysical ones the final point is
that Aristophanes defines this kind of
romantic erotic love in terms of a quest
he says it is the desire of and pursuit
sorry the desire for and pursuit of the
whole
so it's defined in terms of a quest a
Pursuit and that gives rise to the
possibility that if this desire is
consummated if they actually were to be
reunited by the blacksmith God into a
whole
then you cancel out the conditions that
make erotic and romantic love possible
so the idea that Plato explores and
plays around with here is that actually
romantic and indeed erotic but in this
case romantic love is
always an estate of quest is always
looking towards a boundary that it can
never quite reach because we can't
physically be reunited but even if we
could reach that boundary would we want
to because
erotic love and a romantic love is
working towards its own Annihilation if
fully consummated so the idea that there
needs to be the separation this distance
this lack of complete consummation to
keep erotic and a romantic love going
oh
thanks Michael all I'd like to pick up
actually on what Romans just said about
attention it reminds me of a series of
experiments that this I suppose quite
controversial Japanese man called
matsuyamoto did in Japan there's one
particular experiment where he's he's
looking at the effects of human behavior
and this sounds absolutely mad but
anyway he's looking at the effects of
human behavior on rice
so he has this experiment where in his
hallway he has three jars of rice it's
the same rice from the same packet
emptied into three different containers
and on one uh and when he leaves the
house each morning and comes back
to the first one he says I love you
to the second one he says I hate you and
the third one he ignores completely
and he yeah
and uh over time he Maps the effect of
this and uh the first jar to begin to
Decay the rice that begins to
deteriorate is the one that's paid no
attention at all
which suggests to me actually that
perhaps you know we think of love and
hate as being opposites perhaps actually
the true opposite of Love is
indifference
it's not giving any attention to to use
your word at all and for me actually
that's one of the many ways in which
probably love and hate are more
intimately connected than we've they've
then we might think they are
um for a start I don't really believe
that hatred is a Primary Emotion in a
way that love is in other words
I think that hate arises as a reaction
to something
and I say that just not as a matter of
principle but I'm also thinking of
psychoanalyst you talked about post
freudians I was thinking about Melanie
Klein as you were talking she does use
the word hate actually in relation to to
young babies
and she says they will even quite young
babies experience feelings of hatred
towards their mothers when they're not
picked up or fed or held but it's not a
Primary Emotion it's a reaction to the
interruption of the loving bond in some
way
somewhere so although we might think
almost statically like you know love is
here and hatred is there that they're in
some sort of spatial relationship you
can almost think of them as in a
temporal relationship love comes first
and then hatred is a kind of reaction to
it a sort of Revenge on aborted love or
a disappointment a love not getting off
the ground or something like that it's
so hatred has a sort of almost has a
morning for the impossibility of Love
kind of contained within it as if we
most spontaneously or most primarily
would seek a love position
having said that I think uh
to be pure and I'm not suggesting it's
possible but to be pure
I mean love would have to hate the
hateable as well because if you only
love what's lovable if you love what's
lovable in your partner well it's easy
there's no challenge in loving what's
lovable presumably it's only when you
are confronted with what's hateable or
extremely hard to love that the gesture
of Love becomes authentic in some way
so
um you know in philosophical terms this
would be the idea of including the other
you know the the radical otherness of
the other person is such that I hate
them
but even in the midst of my hating them
I then learn to love them because their
otherness is something which I can then
begin to come to terms with so it's an
otherness that allows the other person
in all their horribleness to remain
other
well love certainly doesn't depend on
brain chemicals well I mean brain
chemicals involved in every neural
process neurotransmitters but if you
look at say the love that dogs can have
for humans I mean they undoubtedly love
humans and as some people say when you
get a dog it's the only kind of love
that money can buy and there are better
examples of unconditional love than most
humans I mean only the highest level of
saints can achieve the level of
unconditional love that many dogs show
for their unworthy owners
um so I I and certainly they're not I
mean they may be or they may be
additives in pet food that
um that we don't know about but
um the um it's certainly not just drugs
I mean it's about it's about
relationships and about something to do
with relationship going Beyond
pure immediate personal self-interest
it's about commitment and relationship
to another another person another
organism
and so I think that I think that coming
back to the Transcendent aspect
um I think the mystical aspect the
Transcendent aspect of some psychedelics
is to open people up to this much
greater sense of Love which can exist in
mystical experiences and which often has
a healing effect I mean for example uh
mushrooms psilocybin and other
psychedelics are now being used to treat
as many people know depression and
addictions and they're working not just
because the chemical is affecting
chemicals in the brain they're working
because they induce experiences of
connection
that transcend our normal everyday
mundane lives and give people a sense
that they're part of something much
greater than themselves and as a kind of
loving presence in the universe which
can change their lives in a way that
makes them more loving people so there
there are effects of drugs that can be
transformative but most of the time love
depends on just regular neurochemicals
and uh bonding a connection which takes
people beyond their own limited cells as
as you were saying that so it's it's to
do with relationship
[Music]
foreign